tout comme la ministre la parole est à
monsieur arnaud viala pour les
républicains vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente monsieur le premier
ministre
dimanche par leur vote les français ont
poussé plusieurs cris et ses cris vous
sont adressées le cri des pauvres et des
laissés pour compte
le cri des classes moyennes est aussi le
cri du monde rural de ses territoires
interstitielle que vous nous avons que
nous vous avons si souvent témoigner ici
la france s'est aussi nous dans nos
territoires l'agriculture est en
souffrance et rien ne vient apaiser ces
inquiétudes sur le court terme liées à
la conjoncture ni sur le moyen et long
terme liés à vos hésitations en europe
aux errements de vaud politique
internationale et surtout au fait qu à
répétition vous le marteler votre vision
du monde rural est pétri d'idéaux
environnementaux et dénué de toute
vision économique dynamique ni
l'agriculture ni les autres formes
d'économie ignorons leur place de mai si
vous continuez ainsi et pourtant la
france c'est aussi nous dans nos
territoires l'enjeu et démographiques et
sociales les attentes en matière de
services sont de plus en plus grande et
la capacité à les satisfaire de plus en
plus faible et pourtant la france c'est
aussi nous dans nos territoires il faut
des infrastructures modernes
le gouvernement ne répond pas aux
attentes en matière de numérique de
téléphonie mobile ni de sécurité
sanitaire et pourtant la france c'est
aussi nous pourtant nos territoires
offre énormément davantage dans le
contexte actuel en matière de sécurité
mais surtout de qualité de vie et il
porte des dynamiques très forte
qu'attendez vous pour nous donner de
vrais moyens pour regarder vers demain
qu'attendez vous pour nous dire
clairement si vous voulez poursuivre l'
asphyxie de 80% de la france afin d'en
chasser définitivement les gens qui
vivent et ils sont attachés ou si vous
allez enfin redéfinir votre politique
d'aménagement du territoire
merci monsieur le député l'apport l'état
le premier ministre madame la présidente
monsieur monsieur viala je pourrais vous
répondre d'abord que ces problèmes ces
sujets c'est des filles c'est souffrent
sont là depuis bien longtemps
je pourrais vous répondre précisément
que nous avons engagées sylvia pinel l'a
rappelé il y a un instant déjà depuis
plusieurs mois toutes les actions
indispensables à ces territoires sur les
maisons de service public sur les
maisons de santé sur la couverture sur
le numérique avec un plan sans précédent
qui voit l'engagement de l'état des
conseils départementaux et des
opérateurs qui doivent pleinement assumé
les responsabilités
nous avons encore tenu il ya quelques
mois à vesoul
un comité interministériel présidé par
le chef de l'état sur ces questions là
mais je vais vous dire au fond le fond
de ma pensée à travers votre
intervention avec tout le respect bien
sûr que je vous dois élu député de
l'aveyron département rural comme et
bien d'autres et que beaucoup d'entre
nous connaissent l'idée même d'opposer
dans votre question
plusieurs france l'idée de nous faire
croire ici dans cet hémicycle donc à
travers cet hémicycle les français qu'un
gouvernement d'ailleurs quel qu'il soit
abandonnerait la les territoires urbains
et les banlieues là les territoires
ruraux que nous ne respecterions pas
cette france qui a toujours raison
cette france rurale cette france qui dit
la vérité c'est monsieur le député et je
vous le dis très honnêtement le meilleur
moyen de continuer à conforter l'extrême
droite dans ce même discours
au lieu de tenir ce type de discours au
lieu de poser en permanence plusieurs
france essayons plutôt ensemble
d'apporter les réponses vous faites des
propositions nous agissons rien n'est
jamais parfait il faut être lucide sur
l'action de ces politiques publiques
mais dans ces territoires ruraux en même
temps grâce aux régions grâce au
département grâce à l'intercommunalité
grâce à l'état grâce souvent en effet à
l'union européenne et notre politique de
ce point de vue là mais comment pouvez
vous dire que nous n'agissons pas au
niveau de la pac par exemple
au niveau l'union européenne comment
pouvez vous dire qu'au niveau
international
c'est le cas notamment de l'action du
ministre de l'agriculture pour lever
tous les embargos nécessaires notamment
avec la russie mais c'est ce discours
monsieur le député caricatural qu'il
repose sur aucun fait qu'on a affadi sic
on met en cause le discours et l'action
publique plutôt que le tenir ce discours
essayons de travailler ensemble parce
que au fond c'est ce que les citoyens
dans vos départements comme dans votre
circonscription attendent
assez de ces démagogie un peu plus de
réalisme et de hauteur de vue